and recently I've been involved into a
number of projects with water mission
organization so what're mission is a
non-profit out of Charleston South
Carolina and basically what they are
doing what their purpose is is to be
able to deliver safe water solutions to
communities around the world and they
were founded in 2001 and it mostly
they're doing their work in kind of
developing countries in Asia South
America Africa and they've done a lot in
last 15 years you know hundreds of
products they doing both sanitation
types of projects and water treatment so
I'm mostly going to talk about water
treatment first because that's the side
of their business that we are involved
into and what they're doing in this
space is they allow those communities to
have access to clean water so imagine
you know some kind of village let's say
in Africa they usually have a water
source it could be a river or a lake or
stream or well but what people don't
know that all those data sources they
contaminate it in now some way or
another so just not safe to drink this
water unfiltered so what water mission
does they go into those communities and
they install so-called living water
treatment system which they invented and
it does exactly that that takes water
from those contaminated sources filters
it and then this water is being
delivered to people in this community
now it's not free so the way it's set up
that other mission comes and they build
a kiosk maybe a couple of kiosks where
they set up this within the water
treatment system they would have an
operator actually working in these
kiosks and managing this kiosk and they
were distributed
um like a water card so they call it
smart cars something like credit card to
households in the community and then
people would put money on those cards
and they will use those cards as a kiosk
to pay for clean water now it's done on
purpose it's not free on purpose and the
purpose is that they want those
solutions to be maintained and
sustainable a lot of other organizations
would come like disaster areas all those
remote places and they would do
something you know they would dig a well
or they would install like a filtering
system and it would work and they would
just go away and what happens in a year
maybe here and a half you know the well
gets contaminated something gets broken
the palm who gets broken and nobody is
there to fix it and nobody really cares
so people go back to their usual way
taking the water from Lake right over
river and they get sick and basically
there is no point so what our mission
wants community to DM kind of involves
into this so because they you know they
pay for the water so they know you know
it's not something for free and operator
basically you know get some mine is at
his job and he is interested in and
responsible for maintaining this kiosk
and the community as a whole becomes
kind of a stakeholder in the whole kind
of initiative so for about a year after
other mission installs those costs they
would monitor them so they will send a
technician every month to you know take
all the measurements and they would
analyze how since I goin if something
needs to be fixed they would train
people on site to maintain those
solutions and usual after one year of
this kind of oversight the community is
able to take over it also those kiosk
are able to
stream data through actual some kind of
a cellphone connection into the cloud so
all the transactions all the water
dispensing transactions from those kiosk
actually gets tracked and we have
accessed every one of those transactions
and i'll be showing later on Jupiter
notebook which we use to analyze this
kind of data and do some cool stuff is
that and this is how the kiosk looks
like you can see oh is it building right
and in sizes buildings there is living
water treatment system there is a solar
panel at the top that's how it's all
good powered there is a creator and a
couple of speakers for water dispensing
so our team Jay start we started to work
with water mission in 2015 and we
actually ended up being involved in
multiple projects is m and you know it's
a alerting system we built first version
now we're working on kind of the second
version of that we also started to
create an operational dashboard for them
and we also doing data analysis on this
transactional data and some other data
as well and but all of those I
initiatives they have one common scene
kind of underlying everything it's a
focus on sustainability so all those who
projects you know why we're doing that
is because we want to make sure that
those kiosks stay operational right so
we get alerts you know about something
happening there we deliver the medial
time the water mission personnel so they
can do something about that operational
dashboard the same thing they can look
at what's going on in different projects
that they manage and data analysis that
we perform we actually started to
analyze the data trying to find ways to
improve something and here we didn't
initially we didn't know what can be
improved we are looking for ways to
improve Samsung in the way those kiosk
being operated or managed or promoted or
something that would increase the usage
of polluting water in the community and
get more buy-in from from the people
around so i'll be talking mostly about
this data now as a sub part of it and
the notebook which i'm going to show
that that's about it let me set some
context around it first of all it's not
just one data source so i talked about
this transactional data so it's a water
consumption data every transaction we
have that but we have more than that we
used AP is provided by IBM whether
company to get weather data so for every
day in all those communities we are you
know we have average temperature we have
maximum temperature we have rainfall
amount so all of that influences amount
of water people take from those stations
so we have that data we also know what
are there any seasons in them or in by
the way i'll be talking mostly about
communities in uganda in this case right
and that's the first three communities
we started to look at to do the analysis
so they have to rainy seasons in uganda
one bigger than another so we have that
data but also have social economic data
and again different type of data so we
were able to run some surveys on site in
those communities to find out about
households how many people in every
household what are the occupations how
much money they make you know you know
what they're doing we also know what
their agricultural seasons and again in
those communities they have two seasons
every year and some has date as well and
as i mentioned we have multiple
communities in uganda
we have data for three communities it's
cuando bashira and day and those sir
computers a kind of close together
geographically so we can actually
meaningfully compare what we get what we
see in the data coming from those three
communities and come to conclusions what
is different in those communities and
you know we're trying to answer some
tough questions based on this data and
you know what kind of questions for
instance can we predict water shortage
in a bicycle community or can we predict
water outages water outages could be
just because of a technical failure on
the kiosk or maybe weather-related you
know we don't know so can we predict
that can we predict drought conditions
and also what can we do what can we
recommend them to do in order to
increase usage of order from those
kiosks so some really tough questions
and some of them I still working on and
some of them I'm not even sure we will
be able to answer but the good news that
some of those questions we were able to
answer even now kind of in the middle of
our engagement and what I'm going to
show is kind of an example of data
analysis that we've done using Jupiter
notebooks that kind of illustrates like
a sword process behind water event water
went through right where we started
where we how we looked at the data and
what happened kind of step by step how
we were able to get to some of the
results it's a little bit simplified but
I hope it really illustrates the point
so for this bicycle kissed idea i'll be
looking at the data coming from one of
those communities is geek wanda and we
have more than one year worth of data
coming from this community and this is a
map its own shore of the lake victoria
so they have huge source of water but
it's all contaminated so it's not safe
to drink water from the lake and its
kind of medium-sized village I would say
maybe about three hundred households
there so it's not huge but we have a lot
of data as I said more than one year
every single transaction from the kiosk
um inside the IC we're actually using
spark service on bluemix and notebooks
on bluemix as well I wouldn't say it's
because a huge amount of data I think we
could have do the same just using
straight like pandas but that's what we
used but in this particular demo I'm
going to show it locally on my laptop
because I don't want to go out to
bluemix from here so I have a local
spark cluster setup and and local mobile
let me open it up ok so this is it i
hope everybody can see it well so the
first step is i'll just run it step by
step and I'll talk through the logic
first step is kind of obvious we're
importing a bunch of libraries that we
are going to use i mentioned pandas
numpy using matplotlib i'm actually
using spark or filtering and aggregation
queries here as well and this is how the
data looks like so this particular perky
file contains those water consumption
transactions and every transaction has a
date and it's like day hour minute up to
the seconds it contains a card number
obviously it contains remaining balance
on the card after this transaction and
actually how much water was taken right
and some other information but those are
kind of the important pieces
so the first thing we wanted to do after
we've got this data file it's okay let's
see how much water in this community is
being dispensed every day so that's kind
of natural first step to analyze the
data set and in order to do that we need
to aggregate the data by base so all
those transactions has to be merged
together so that's what I'm doing this
step and I'm reaching the first ten days
and you can see like they started to use
this kiosk and I think it's probably
just test this kiosk in may 2015 so the
first three days just a little bit of
water suspends they probably testing it
and then it goes from there right and
people actually started to use the kiosk
and amount is in witters over here so
now when we have this aggregated set let
some float it on a chart so what I want
to see at this point is kind of an
overall trend of water consumption over
this year it going up is going down so
that's what I'm doing a museum numpy to
calculate the trend line and then I'm
going to plot it and this is how it
looks like so Biggers that I wanted but
basically you can see what's going on so
it's not good right so clearly the trend
is going down over the year it's not
kind of precipitous down but it is down
so something is not going well at this
particular location of this community so
as soon as we saw the chart we were in
the motorcade let's look at the data and
see you can we find some clues what I
the trend is going down is there some
kind of intervention that we can make to
reverse the trend right you know wait
how do we do it you know where do we
start so we have this data okay we
actually went from different angles we
looked at whether we looked at some
other stuff
and finally the best solution that kind
of made our next step possible was
really brute force so what we did we
just said okay it's not such a bigger
community it's like 300 houses they
distributed maybe about 180 cards so
this community let just print them all
so basically ended up printing 180
charts of individual consumption for
every card and then we looked at those
charts I'm not going to print 180 but
I'm going to print 5 so you'll see what
it is so this is what we got right so we
got those individual charts 40
individual cards right and if I just sat
down and I looked at those charts it
took me I maybe half an hour and two
sport some patterns how people use their
cards and even in those five you can see
like this one that's what you want to
see so this chart basically shows that
this bicycle household probably every
second day they would go to the kiosk
and get some water about 40 league
leaders and they do it throughout the
year no big contraptions that's a
pattern we want to see right well this
second choice is the K as well so they
assign not quitting the taking water
maybe they taking a little less water
now than they used to and something that
maybe we should be addressed but look at
this one or even this one all those
three then what happens here we see that
this household they started to use a
card they use it for a while and then
they stopped so well that's obviously
not good so we saw a bunch of those in a
data set so we saw a lot of cars with
this particular pattern so they use it
and there's a stop right and then there
is no usage so now the next question
okay why did they stop so you started
thinking about that there could be
multiple reasons why they could stop so
maybe they just ran out of money on the
card and they decided not to reuse a
balance and they just quit so another
possibility could be maybe they just
lost their cards right and for whatever
reason is hard for them to get the
replacement card so there could be
different reasons right so you know we
would try to investigate and see what
can we see in the data about that so
let's see if we have really stung yeah
first of all how many cards are in this
inactive condition right so let's look
at that so this step I'm just taking the
last date in this data set and the one
I'm using for the damn it ends at the
end of July now we have August data but
this one is end of July and then I'm
calculation for every card I'm
calculating what is the last day for the
last transaction on this bicycle card
and even on this 10 cars sample you can
see that there are cards that have this
end of july as the last date but there
are cars like you know me there is like
jun 2015 even right so those cars are
you Liz stopped right so you can see
that some cards I still run you some
cards I inactive right now if you look
at this 728 it's not exactly 731 it's
not the last date in the data set but
it's close enough so it is this card
clearly the active right so we cannot
mark it as a stop card so I'm doing a
little trick over here in the next step
I'm actually updating this date and if
the date is close enough and clothes
would be four weeks right it is close
enough to the last day of the data set
I'm going to update this date and make
it 731 so we will not treat this bicycle
card as inactive well that's kind of my
next step so now this 728 was turned
into 731 so at this point I can actually
calculate the card and say okay total
amount of cars we have 181
and seventy-seventh of those are
inactive as a big number of cards after
one year of operation so cailloodles
there is a problem right so just cars
getting out of the system as probable is
the reason why the consumption is going
down we don't know for sure but we
suspect that has something to do with
that so the next step okay let's find
out out of those 77 cards how many cars
are actually lost campaigning to the
cars or where they went out of money and
decided not to use them anymore so to
check that we need to look at the
remaining balance on those cards so
that's what I'm doing on this next step
I'm just looking at the balance and if
the balance of the card is actually more
than 2 i'm saying on cases card has some
money it is less than 2 it has no money
and this take maybe a couple of seconds
and now we have 45 cards with non zero
balance so other 7745 cars is probably
genuinely lost so people just lost cards
with the money on them and for whatever
reason they're not replacing them yes
question
yeah we looked at the gap sexual that's
one of the null analysis we've done with
noises of a lot of cars have gaps and we
looked at 10-day gaps 20-day gaps in 30
day gaps right and we actually
discovered that those gaps I kind of
clustered correlated with rainy seasons
so during the rainy seasons you would
see a lot of those gaps which actually
not something we want to see maybe more
education needs to be done those
communities that rainwater may not be as
clean as they sink right but that's
where the gaps come from so yeah I agree
some of those lost cards maybe just the
gaps right but we think that most of
them I really lost okay so now we have
this 45 out of 77 okay so let's uh let's
just modify our data set a little bit so
for every day now we have how many
active cars we had in the system and how
many cars were lost right so we have
that and at this point we can start
closing some additional charts just to
double check our suspicions you know
once in that well on the next shot
amount about it this very very simple
chart so we have active cards going down
and lost cars going up you know why this
chart is important it basically shows
that this number of postcards going up
gradually there is no like a simple
single jump when something happened and
everybody lost their cars and the same
is active cars is gradual going down so
it's kind of flicking cars from the
system one by one and it actually
correlates very well with the trend line
that we saw in the first chart and the
same gradient so we know at this point
okay it's not like one event that
happened in below the cars is just
gradual leaking out of the system okay
well lets you know
I'm still not at the point where I can
come to the conclusion but let's look at
this this way okay maybe there is also
like people just taking less water right
so and we saw it on some of the cars
they started to take a lot of water and
then goes down right so maybe that's
what's happening say just the user cars
but they take less water so I want to
actually have a chart for that so I'm
going to calculate in order to make this
chart I need to know how many cards were
used every day so I would call it unique
cars it's like for every day how many
cars were used in the kiosk and then if
I know that number i can look at total
water consumption for this day divided
by the number of cars and I would know
how much water on average was used so I
have that and now i can print this chart
and well what I see is kind of what I
expected and almost hope to see that the
trend line for daily average transaction
per card per day is kind of stays the
same so people who is still using this
system they've been taking about 50
liters per day and they still do the
same so it's not going up it's not going
down it's the same number so it's really
looks like it's a number of cards
because if the car does exit that's how
much what is it gonna take now it's
different point that we would like
people to take more water over time and
actually some of the communities in this
bush 0 community another village in
Uganda we actually have the trend going
up this one but stain fled is fine as
well so people using the same amount of
water every day so that's kind of ruled
out so the next step okay let's just
final confirm our suspicions and on this
chart i'm going to plot my number of
lost cars versus daily water consumption
and on this chart is actually pretty
clear you can see when we have more and
more loss cards those water consumption
just going down so it's basically going
through this kind of thought process for
the set of steps and again it's a little
bit simplified here but you know we were
able to come to those i wouldn't say
definite proofs but very high
probability kind of suspicions that
that's what's going on there so if i go
back to my chart that's that's what we
came up with and we talked to water
mission as a result of this analysis and
came up with some recommendations so
first let's address those lost cars um
we ask a question in why people are not
buying new cars when they lost the ones
that they have and what we found out
from water mission that they set it up
in a way that it's actually prohibitive
for people to buy replacement card I
guess when they started the program they
saw the k let's make it expensive to buy
replacement card so people would be more
careful with their cards and they will
not lose it but what we see is happening
that people still lose their cars but
because it's expensive to buy
replacement cards they just not buying
it and that's the end of it so what we
recommended water vision to do is kind
of change this policy and make it
affordable or more affordable for people
to buy replacement cards or maybe even
distribute replacement cards that's our
second point we want to run an
experiment in this particular village
you know you know we can buy a bunch of
cars ourselves and just distribute it to
the households that blows our cars and
then monitor water consumption for maybe
20 3 months and see what happens so if
that experiments confirms our suspicion
if the trend is going to be reversed
then yes that's that's what we should do
another
communities as well just keep the number
of cars in the system kind of constant
or growing and the third one is at the
very beginning of the project we think
that it might be beneficial instead of
giving just one card to a household i
will give two or three like you know you
go to harris teeter or louis you get
your VIP card you get like a bunch of
them so if you lose one you have the
rest of them so the same idea here so
let's just distribute several cards at
the same time so if they lose one they
have replacement on hand so that's
that's where all recommendations end up
I'm glad to say that actually two days
ago our main contact person from water
mission she went to Uganda and she's
going to visit this bicycle community
talk to people on site and I hope that
some of those recommendations could be
applied kind of very soon right and in
the future projects again if what we
discovered indeed holds ground maybe a
water mission will adjust their
processes and make it better for the
rest of the communities as well and I
think that's all I have so thank you
very much any questions yes
good sorry what is it possible for them
to use like an account ID or account
number like you had referenced in your
code if they could just remember that
and then give it to the person in a key
Oscar they actually have to have the
physical card right now they have to
have a physical card to get money and
even more at the beginning some of the
communities they were allowing people to
pay in cash right but they basically
said that they don't want it because
it's not being tracked in any way so
they kind of forced everybody to use the
card so you cannot go to yours can just
pay cash and get water you know we've
seen interesting behaviors as it is the
transaction log people would go to the
kiosk they run their card and we here in
transactions that says all you have zero
balance on your card so what happens
next we see a financial transaction from
a cart of the operator to the cart of
this person some money has been
transferred and then the next
transaction the water has been taken so
what how we understand the sequence is a
person come to the Cure's wants to get
water swipe their card oh I don't have
any money this is my cash right and
apparatus that's okay I'll take your
cash this is some crazies on your card
how flexible is price so if you want to
track if you lower the price of water
for example you can measure if the use
of ID cards increase that's a good point
we actually did not think about that at
least we did not ask water mission with
its it's an option to change the price
so somehow is set it's not expensive
right so it's literally like if you want
to take 50 liters is sense right it's
not expensive but it is some money and
for those communities obviously it's
more than working in the United States
but that's a good point next time
doctors my losses question hello so I
had a few questions about sort of how
the program is run or how you're
planning on I guess your organization is
planning on running it over the long
term so it almost I guess what I'm kind
of curious about is like what are the
thoughts or plans on how to get like the
community to like own their own water
system and like make themselves like
self-sufficient or is that is that
acolyte yes that's exactly as a goal and
that's why they pay for the water so the
idea behind it that if enough people in
the community by enough water so this
money that they spend would be enough to
pay salary of the operator and
maintenance costs and if that happens in
the communities and water mission just
hands it over so they don't get
reimbursement for the initial setup they
just hand it over because there is
enough money in the system now to
maintain and sustain this kiosk so one
other question is there someone had
asked me if the Jupiter notebook is
available somewhere are you gonna make
that available yeah well it means the
demo oh yeah I probably can make it
available its kind of Demma I'm not sure
about the data I would need to talk to
water mission about that okay so there
is a chance that for the cards that had
more than 22 dollars you just assumed
they were lost but why is there a
possibility that there's some cuts that
had money but people just knows not
using them for other reasons I'm sorry I
did what I so you assumed that the cards
that had money but we're no longer being
used to a loss right like the card the
head like more than two dollars bar not
being used were lost oh well the two is
not dollars it's like she knows it's
very very very small
okay let's call them Schilling so is
there a possibility that they were cards
with more than two shillings but we're
not being used for the reasons yes and
we have some cards in the system like
that so i had 45 cards with the money
that no nobody's using we're singing
they lost there might be other reasons I
agree but you know we can think of any
so maybe it's one of those gaps like as
a person mentioned there so it may be a
prolonged gap maybe as this particular
family in some of them they like
postural so they would have um I'm sure
kettle but some kind of a livestock
right and they may go for you know a
month somewhere else and they just note
in the village so that might be
happening but I think most of those cars
are actually lost is is there a point of
contact within each of these communities
that you guys reach out to in terms of
like analyzing the data so someone that
could help you explain or interpret the
trends that you see yeah kind of
indirect so we work with water mission
and they have people in the US here who
are managing they call them projects
right in different countries so there is
a person responsible let's say for this
particular community in Uganda for the
project so we can communicate with this
person and this person does have access
to local people and can ask them
questions and we actually had some of
our questions answered but it's kind of
it's not a direct communication so
sometimes you know we get an answer
sometimes we don't get an answer
sometimes we kind of so we will say we
suggest less than just more cards right
we suggested that a number of weeks ago
this person communicated to the local
community person and they were kind of
why should we do that right so now this
person going to Uganda
basically physically going to Uganda and
we'll talk to the staff on site about
that and present some proof or our
suspicions that might help so very
interesting presentation thank you so
much so there I read somewhere that
Vodafone I was so initiating something
that would enable people in Africa rural
parts of India to exchange money or pay
through SMS to mobiles like very simple
handsets so I'm not sure how the data
connectivity or the network available
network availability is in that part of
the region but it would be lot easier to
do all the transactions through like a
mobile or a cell right you could even
collect data by sending messages or
information do payments yeah things yeah
it might be an option actual and again
maybe based on our research here what
our mission will decide to change their
system with cars and everything
completely who knows but as far as
connect series here there they do have
connectivity you'd be surprised you know
we talked to what their mission people
they would say like everybody has a cell
phones there you know they can make
calls but not everybody has access to
water so sometimes they need to call
somebody to find out all this well four
hours away from my current place does it
have water should I go there a lot right
so those kind of questions but they have
cell phones and they have connectivity
there so again it might be an option but
it's for what their mission they decide
if they want to go that route thank you
well another round of applause for
Vladimir thank you so much
you